Uber's meteoric rise to dominate the
personal transport market has made it
one of the most successful and the most
hated companies in history along with
this controversial CEO Travis kalanick
it has developed a reputation as being
iron fisted cruel and relentless in its
pursuit of power inspiring an equal
measure of admiration and loathing uber
has turned the traditional taxi industry
on its head and provided customers with
a more user-friendly way of getting from
point A to point B in the mid-1990s with
the world wide web still in its infancy
the undergraduate computer science
association or usca at UCLA University
in sunny California was a breeding
ground for future millionaires the
association was more of a clubhouse
where like-minded students could relax
after class while they played games and
toured computers though not a founding
member a young San Fernando Valley
resident by the name of Travis kalanick
soon became a central figure of the
group Callen ik was pursuing a double
major in computers and business just
like the movement internet companies up
north in Silicon Valley the usca was
mostly about fun games however soon its
members stumbled upon an opportunity
because there were no firewalls back
then it was possible to search for files
on all connected computers and then
index the results the group decided to
replicate the time-honored practice of
college kids lending out their record
albums but they were able to extend the
lending fraternity to anybody who was
connected to the Internet the idea was
molded into a startup which they named
scour it was a tool that would scrubber
networks files looking for mp3's Travis
kalanick was not involved in the
founding of Scour because he was doing
an internship with Intel but as Scour
became established and grew in
popularity he jumped on board he was in
charge of marketing and fundraising it
was in this role that Callen ik
developed the on-the-job training that
would serve him in later years living at
his parents house he would spend up to
eight hours a day on the phone wheeling
and dealing in order to attract
investors in 1999 his efforts paid off
when Hollywood Power player Michael
Ovitz port
four million dollars in to scour in
return for a 51% share in the company
within a year however the writing was on
the wall for scour its success had
attracted a competitor who would do
things better this competitor was
Napster scours fundamental problem was
that it didn't scale the site was often
crashed through overuse and scour was
running out of fresh content meanwhile
Napster was paying close attention to
scours problems they introduced a tweak
whereby listening to a song would
automatically make it available to
others as a result Napster quickly
became a viral sensation scour tried to
gain grounds by moving into sharing
movie files but ultimately they were
doomed the company went into bankruptcy
in 2000 by the end of that year with
Scour gone 24-year old Travis kalanick
had no college degree and no job he
needed a new plan and he needed it fast
within weeks of the folding of Scour
Callen ik who was on to his next project
he teamed up with former scour partner
Michael Todd to form red swoosh which
was essentially Scour recreated for
business customers this new startup
would allow companies to use the
Internet to share similarly large files
with their customers enabling large file
movement was already big business but
red swooshes competitive advantage was
that it capitalized on the asset light
strategy to keep its costs below that of
competitors red swoosh pushed and pulled
files from personal computers owned by
others foreshadowing what uber would
later do in connecting riders with
drivers whose cars represented massive
unused capital on city streets as the
CEO of red swoosh kolonics job was to
pitch the potential clients as he had
done at scour he sat a frantic work base
proving to be the quintessential
workaholic despite his gargantuan
efforts however red swoosh became a
victim of the peaking of the internet
bubble investments dried up and tensions
rose colonic blamed Todd for
mismanagement Sims wrangled for him to
be kicked out of the company colonic
kept wheeling and it looked as if he had
found a savior on September the 11th
2001 he was scheduled to meet with a
potential partner investor named Danny
Lewin Lewin however was on board
American Airlines flight 11 from Boston
to Los Angeles which cash
to the North Tower of the World Trade
Center it is thought that he was the
first to die after confronting the
hijackers by the end of 2001 ret swoosh
was out of money reprieve came in the
form of a father-and-son team who had
made a fortune from a semiconductor
business James and Jared Chow they
agreed to pour three hundred thousand
dollars into the business in return for
a 30% stake over the next few years read
swoosh stumbles along propped up by
further investments as then in April of
2007 major competitor Akamai purchased
the company hiring the handful of
employees of the company including
colonic colonic was now 31 years old for
his share in the sale of read swoosh he
had pocketed around three million
dollars yes he was now tied to a large
corporation as an employee something he
had never experienced before
over the next year he worked to continue
building the read swoosh brand at the
same time he restyled himself as an
angel investor for young entrepreneurs
he bought an old house in the Castro an
old San Francisco neighborhood and named
it the champ at Dallas became the
meeting place for fresh tech based ideas
with no money Callan ik reveled in the
role of wiser older sage who had been
there and done that his blog which was
called swishing became essential reading
in it he described his home the jam pad
as a place where entrepreneurs regularly
come to hang out to wrap on ideas to jam
with other entrepreneurs to play Wii
tennis and Gears of War and to have
fantastic healthy gourmet meals made by
the jam pads in-house chef Callen egg
quit red swoosh in late 2008 he spent
the next couple of years biding his time
as he examined new business ventures he
also threw himself into leisure
activities he became a part of a group
called the random traveler Society they
would randomly spin a globe do you
decide where in the world they would
travel in 2010 kalanick got heavily
involved with a Q&A website called
formspring he invested in the company
that was soon running the show at the
same time he was still looking for other
opportunities he was introduced to a
smartphone app by the idea of an old
friend named Garrett camp the app was
called uber cab and it allowed the user
to make quick contact with a limousine
in the San Francisco area kalanick began
sharing his time between formspring and
uber cab
within a few months it became obvious
that he had to choose between them the
people at formspring were pushing him to
become their si
but in late September 2010 he walked
into a board meeting and declared I'm
going to the uber in the summer of 2008
Garrett camp a mild-mannered Canadian
software designer was waiting for a cab
in San Francisco's Bay Area he'd been
waiting nearly 30 minutes for a cab that
had promised to be there in just 15 when
he saw an empty cab from a competitor
company come by he hailed it and got in
a few minutes later though he got a call
from the original taxi company asking
where he was he replied that they were
late so he'd gotten in another taxi this
became a regular occurrence for camp
eventually both taxi companies that he
dealt with Luxor and yellow blacklisted
him this annoyed the young Canadian who
just so happened to have 75 million
dollars in his bank account after
selling his first startup StumbleUpon
hailing a cab was now more difficult for
camp the taxi switchboard companies who
had cut him off as soon as they saw his
number one evening while standing on a
street corner and running late for a
date he had the proverbial light bulb
moment he had his brand new Apple iPhone
in his hands that phone was GPS enabled
why couldn't he request a cab directly
from his phone simply by pushing a
button that says pick me up this way you
cut out the dispatcher entirely cab also
knew that the iPhone included a thing
called an accelerometer this allowed for
the tracking of not just where a car was
but also how fast it was moving with
this technology a map could be generated
that showed the beginning and end of the
trip along with its duration and price
it would also blink the rider with the
driver cutting out the middleman on
August the 8th 2008 campaign $35 to
reserve the website
uber cab con he then began to elicit
feedback about his idea from his circle
of entrepreneurial friends he also
interviewed a taxi driver who complained
about the hours that they were sitting
idly waiting for a fare slowly other
people began jumping on board one of
them was Travis kalanick in early 2009
Travis contributed an idea that became
pivotal to the future of the uber model
rather than buying a fleet of vehicles
which camp was envisioning Callen ik
told him that he didn't need to buy cars
just give the app to drivers and let
them be free agents they would work when
they wanted to work the focus for both
men was on limousine rides rather than
normal taxi cab rides Callen ik signed
on as an advisor
you go with a 10% stake in the company
it took over a year to develop the app
by January 2010 camping colonic began
testing the service they also began
making plans to launch operations in San
Francisco Kallen acquired a 27 year old
general electric middle management
employee named Ryan graves to oversee
the San Francisco launch Graves began
visiting garages to sign up limo drivers
the service launched in late May of 2010
with just a handful of drivers and
customers the original customer base
came from Twitter followers who had been
keeping tabs on what the entrepreneurs
were up to Callen Icahn Graves who had
been a CEO again working together to
find investors after receiving a lot of
knockbacks the seed funding round raised
1.25 million dollars it was at this
point that Callen egg decided to go
full-time with uber cab but he wasn't
content to play second fiddle to a guy
that he had hired he orchestrated a
demotion for Graves and claims the title
of CEO for himself he also demanded that
his shareholding rise from 10% to 23% on
the very day that canonic became CEO the
company received a cease-and-desist from
the San Francisco Metro Transit
Authority and California Public
Utilities Commission it stated that the
name booba cab meant that they were a
taxi cab company and under the
authority's direction Callen egg solved
this problem in five seconds he simply
changed the name of the company from who
the cab to simply uber at the time of
his taking over the operation it was
tiny and it made plenty of mistakes on
Halloween of 2010 they offered a
discount to riders this created such a
huge demands on their already busiest
day yet that it left a lot of people
unable to get a ride
despite this growth was steady
throughout 2010 then over the 2011 New
Year period it absolutely blew up
word-of-mouth was responsible for the
exponential growth in ubers customer
base but finding limo drivers while it
was a different story they didn't have
the same social media habits as the
young about towners in need of a limo
ride only licensed drivers were eligible
to drive for uber
they all had customers of their own and
none of them were prepared to go
exclusive with uber uber began giving
away iphones preloaded with the uber app
to drivers this enabled them to increase
their driver supply to keep up with the
ever growing demand in San Fran
having proven the model in San Francisco
Callen ik started to replicate it in
other cities under the guidance of the
head operations Ryan graves they turns
their attention to Seattle Chicago
Boston and Washington DC in each city
graves made connections in the tech
world first this created buzz and
attracted cutting-edge users once the
word was being generated they began
looking for drivers and working through
government regulations as they moved
from city to city the uber team began
refining their PlayBook refining the
system and making us more efficient this
process became one established buzz in
the tech community to assess regulations
three recruit drivers four developed
pricing five we local media and six
capitalized with social media buzz in
the early days Callen ik was a master at
local public relations promotion would
start with the blog post in which you
would relate how much he loved the city
where they were moving into he would
highlight its key attributes and then he
would talk about how much greater the
city would be when uber had introduced
their service by 2011 the job of
securing investment it was much easier
in February benchmark capital poured ten
million dollars into the company at this
point uber was valued at sixty million
dollars the company at nine thousand
customers and one point eight million
dollars in net revenue it was estimated
that it would get to 100 million dollars
gross revenue within a year it achieved
that goal in six months
as we burst sprang up in more and more
cities across America it began to
receive pushback the 6th city that it
went into was Washington DC before they
could get it off the ground however the
city's taxi commissioner announced that
uber was operating an illegal taxi
operation on Martin Luther King Day 2011
the Commissioner ordered an uber which
took him to a press conference at the
Mayflower Hotel he then proceeded to
impound the drivers car and issued a
$20,000 ticket but either they didn't
back down they assured all drivers that
they would pay all of their fines and
took the moral high ground in public
asserting that they were not a taxi
company and therefore not subject to
regulatory provisions in one city after
another taxi companies the taxi
Commission and local and state agencies
came as uber to shut it down under the
guidance of consultant bradley tusk uber
fought back
they ran social media campaigns to stop
the opposes often meeting them in court
the public were overwhelmingly on the
side of the company but there was one
thing that boobas customers were not
happy about during busy periods such as
rush hour and bar closing times it would
apply surge pricing with the rates going
up during these peak demand times surge
pricing had the effect of encouraging
more drivers to work and encouraging
some customers to find a cheaper service
both of these results eased demand on
the service but it also infuriated the
customer base many of them blamed the
unfairness of surge pricing at the foot
of CEO kalanick who quickly became known
as a cutthroat businessman who refused
to listen to consumer sentiment by the
end of 2012
uber was operating in 27 locations in
that year they also introduced hoover x
providing rides in hybrid cars but it
was also the year that uber faced its
first serious competition it came from a
young san francisco company called lift
lift was a ride-sharing business whereby
a person would slap a large pink
moustache on the grille of their car and
then pick up those who are in need of a
ride for the shared cost of gas and a
little extra donation usually this would
work out to be less than the cab fare
for the same distance it used a
smartphone app that was modeled off the
uber app lyft was a hit with young
people who preferred its friendlier more
laid
image riding in a limo was starting to
look elitist as a result Luba set about
restructuring its game plan it would
rebrand itself with a focus on getting a
rider from point A to point B as quickly
and inexpensively as possible
uberx which had started out as an
eco-friendly alternative to a limo
became the means of beating traditional
taxi services in early 2014 collinear
card former Amazon executive chef Holden
as product development manager Holden
identified two things he found lacking
in the uber system the ability of the
rider to communicates beforehand where
he wanted to go and the drivers ability
to navigate there he oversaw two new
features to fix this destination input
by the rider and turn-by-turn navigation
on the driver app both features were a
hit by the end of 2004 uber was
operating in two hundred and sixty two
markets worldwide uber was now a genuine
phenomenon but it was a phenomenon that
had attracted a lot of enemies now a lot
of that animosity was thanks to the
brash nature of the CEO Travis kalanick
his outspokenness and inability to hold
his tongue made him the offender in
chief colonic was the poster boy for
political incorrectness once stating
that he could land women as quickly as a
person could summon an uber
colonics divisive personality only
underscored his growing reputation as a
bully in the marketplace reports were
publicized of some underhanded tactics
used to undermine competitor lyft
publications begin labeling
uber as an evil company and describing a
CEO as an an rands loving libertarian
nutjob in subsidies it became
politically correct to avoid we were all
together
uber was in a strange position worldwide
its business was growing from strength
to strength at the same time however its
reputation was tanking things went from
bad to abysmal when an uber driver in
Delhi was convicted of raping a
passenger something had to be done and
it had to be done quick in 2015 we were
brought on a new executive to oversee
digital and physical safety Joe Sullivan
he had a long to-do list including
stricter management of driver activity
things were tightened up to the extent
that uber management can tell if a
driver is holding his phone while
driving
or braking too hard or going too fast
during that year another new executive
Sally Kay
set about taking and overcoming a slew
of local regulators who were intent on
stopping uber in its tracks by the
beginning of 2016
uber was on a more even keel rather than
lurching from one crisis to another in
an attempt to change its image the
company teamed up with Mothers Against
Drunk Driving to encourage young people
to take an uber rather than drink and
drive it also partnered with hospitals
to make it cheaper for cancer patients
to return home from treatments Travis
kalanick has been working on introducing
driverless cars to the uber mix since
2013 he loved the idea that it would no
longer rely on the most
uncontrollable of business variables
people what anima sphericals would be
far safer as robots are not subject to
drowsiness or distraction further robots
would be cheaper than people but in 2013
the technology it wasn't ready yet by
February of 2014
uber was canvassing the world looking
for top robotics Talent I purchased a
Pittsburg company called Carnegie
robotics making it the kernel of its
self-driving car team then in December
of 2014 Eva hired 60 researchers from
the National robotics Engineering Center
after two years of development we were
announced in August 2016 that it's cars
were ready for a limited showing the
cars worked but they still required a
human engineer behind the steering wheel
just in case something went wrong
uber are today still working on their
driverless car in that quest they are in
a race with the likes of Google Apple
and Tesla the latter of which is rumored
to be considering its own ride-sharing
business all of this competition will
ultimately result in a better cheaper
service for those of us who are wanting
to get from point A to point B as
effectively and cost efficiently as
possible
so I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographic if you did there's
a couple of things you could do right
now one is hit that like button below
also if you want more stuff like this we
put out brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archived
over there on the right and as always
thank you for watching